- Do we have any
content for today?
- [Other Tyler] Not really.
- Not really?
Alright, let me do it.
Hey guys.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
Hey guys. I know today's been
kind of a classic Monday.
Just a bunch of different
meetings and nothing
too meaty for you so...
("Koroko" by Goatlife Beats)
So anyway, I think that,
I think that
we can do cool cultural stuff
like, take a break week
where you work
on different stuff.
Like just good stuff.
It's a great way
for us to mix people.
So we create little
four-person teams that
don't work together and
that creates culture, right?
So there's some really,
I would probably
pay to have four people
like a four person beta team.
Like creative,
accounts, strategy, paid
Four people to
work together for a week
that don't work together,
I'd probably pay
to do that because
I think it'd be positive
for our five year
macro for our business
getting paid (censored)
for the weeks' worth
of work is a good idea.
A, to be very frank,
I love that.
I love that there's
no hardcore obvious thing
that they can
make an episode around.
I love that, Tyler. I love
that you have nothing,
because it's
just boring execution.
You know, this is
the point of the vlog.
The point is people think
entrepreneurship or success
is the bullshit photo
of you at Coachella
or you on a private plane
or you and your boys
or your girls
champagne-ing it up.
The reality is 99% of
successful entrepreneurship
is just like ax to the tree.
Just grinding like fucking
milking the fucking cow.
Fucking milking the cow.
Do you understand?
Thanks.
("Koroko" by Goatlife Beats)
- [Man] That's me.
Okay. Awesome.
- Awesome. We'll be in touch.
- [Man] Sounds good.
- [Gary] It's not sexy.
It's not the thing that
headlines are written about.
It's not what I'm going to put
on my fucking Snapchat.
It's just the truth.
Like, meeting after meeting.
Went up to a client
in White Plains, come back here.
Meeting, meeting,
meeting, meeting,
meeting, meeting, meeting.
- Bro, he was like, why
don't I send you the message?
I don't know it's
just fucking exploring.
- Going through it, yeah.
- Even when I saw it bro,
I was just fucking
like addicted to it,
you know what I mean?
- Appreciate it, man.
- And you know, I'm a big
believer everything happens
for a reason when it does.
- Yeah. If you just DM
that person, be like awesome--
- Right, right. Yeah.
- Then they'll
be like holy shit,
Like it will open
up shit all of a sudden
when you do that and you do
awesome as a Giants punter,
whether they know you or not.
Next thing you know,
couple months from now,
they're doing a
meeting with you.
- [Brad] Right,
right. Yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
That's what I'm good at.
I'm good at looking at shit
and being like, okay.
- [Brad] Yeah.
- [Gary] It's all the
off the field shit.
- Yeah, oh absolutely.
- Investing, the money.
- Well because your
life's this long and
your football life's this long.
- 100 percent.
- So, do everything you can--
- Do me a favor.
- Yeah?
- DM people.
- Yeah.
- Do me one favor.
Take one piece
of advice from me.
DM ten, every day,
in the same way that you
fucking practice
for three hours.
Ten DMs. Five to fans.
Hashtag punter, hashtag giants.
- Yeah.
- Be like, yo thank, right?
- And five to just
fucking people that
you want to get like.
- Connect like you. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Fucking work.
- Like, you should
definitely do that.
- Yeah, I'll do that
as soon as I leave here.
- Good.
Alright. Keep me updated.
- Absolutely, Gary.
I really appreciate this.
- Oh a real pleasure, man, yeah.
- Oh yeah, for sure. Absolutely.
Thanks for everything, bro.
("Atani X Quel") by Goatlife Beats
- [Gary] Have a good day.
See you later, bro.
- Like, you know to me
this is the best
part of this episode
which is me looking
directly in your fucking face
and telling you like great,
I understand what you want
I understand what
it looks like from afar
with all the
people that are winning.
the truth is it's
99 percent of eating shit,
99 percent of milking cows,
99 percent of
fucking axing trees.
It's the non-sexy
shit that is the foundation
to successful entrepreneurship.
What can I help you with?
Tell me everything.
I don't know if you know
this but literally there are
Five to ten thousand applicants
for this job, these 30 jobs.
So it's like overwhelmingly
humbling how many people want in
and so is there anything
that I can answer for you?
Alright, 7:30, I've got
two drinks meetings right now
One client, one with
Ben Leventhal, CEO of Rezy.
Startup that we
co-founded, but he's really
the man behind it all,
him and his team, Ontar,
those guys. Anyway,
we'll catch you up later,
I've got a little bit of
a meeting that I think you
might be able to
join later, but if not
this is it.
Just another grinder
another typical Monday
being an entrepreneur.
("Atani X Quel") by Goatlife Beats
(laughs) I'll see you later.
9:30 P.M., walking into
a sushi business dinner
should get out
of here around 11:30.
Another kind of
classic 16 hour day.
You heard my rant earlier.
Nothing too fancy.
had two productive
meetings just now and
now with the
very big idea meeting
and I know Babin's
excited about so
lots of fun stuff.
Hope you're
grinding on your stuff.
I appreciate your time.
I was thinking a lot about
people allocating
12, 15, 20,
30, 47 minutes
for the last episode of
peoples' time to my content.
Very flattered. I hope
I'm bringing you the value.
Episode like this,
I may not say something,
it may not be a detail like
the DM business development
or some motivational
quote in a keynote,
but I really believe
that this episode is
a perfect microcosm
of the value of DailyVee.
Like, 98 percent of this
is not going to be memorable,
but it's the body of work
of 27 years of watching
somebody grind 15 hours a day,
that's why the thing happened
is an important lesson
for everybody that thinks
shortcuts or systems
or passive this...
There's no passive,
there's no shortcut.
It's fucking hours and
hours and hours of grinding.
Doing the right thing,
bringing people value.
Rinse and repeat.
Have talent, have a strategy,
work hard, work smart,
day in and day out.
Monday night, 9:30 P.M.
What are you doing on a
Monday night at 9:30 P.M.?
Are you about to walk into
another two hour meeting?
By the way, if your ambition
doesn't speak to
you having to be in
business meetings
to 11:30 on weeknights
then that's great.
Everybody has different
KPIs but make sure your actions
back up your fucking mouth.
("Atani X Quel") by Goatlife Beats